j'aurais souhaité la bienvenue dans
notre belle cité de grand-bassam
bienvenue chez vous à grand bassam
étant donné que nous sommes au début
d'une année je voudrais avant d'entrer
dans le vif du sujet vous offrir mes
voeux de ben et sainte-anne et 2020 pour
vous et les membres de vos familles
respectives
photo institué le cadre il s'agit de
préhistoire
je vais donc chemine avec vous pendant
quelques minutes sur ce qui a fait de
moi l'homme que je suis aujourd'hui
le maire de la ville de grand bassam
l'ambassadeur
le directeur général de la société des
aéroports et la météorologie de côte
d'ivoire
cette histoire en réalité d'un petit
blanc qui a quitté très tôt sa côte
d'ivoire natale et qui durant plus de
vingt années a vécu à l'extérieur sur
plusieurs continents en europe en france
en suisse en amérique du nord au canada
et aux états unis
en dépit de cet éloignement géographique
je suis demeuré très très attaché à ma
terre d'origine
hama ville grand bassam à ma culture
même si je n'en étais pas pleinement
imprégné et à mon pays la côte d'ivoire
donc très tôt est né ce désir de servir
mon pays de servir mon continent
l'afrique et de contribuer modestement à
changer les choses parce que lorsqu'on
se trouve à l'extérieur en position de
spectateur
on observe les choses parfois avec un
petit peu de dépit et on se dit mais
pourquoi est ce que les choses ne sont
pas faites de telle ou telle manière
on enrage parfois et on a envie de
changer les choses et bien donc après ce
long cheminement académique et
universitaire à l'extérieur j'ai choisi
à la différence de la majorité des
membres de ma famille qui se trouvent en
europe et au canada
j'ai choisi de rentrer pour travailler
en côte d'ivoire pour mettre mon
expérience mon savoir être mon savoir
faire à la disposition de mon pays de ma
communauté
trois éléments fondamentaux trois
valeurs ont toujours guidé mon être et
ont contribué fortement à définir la
personne que je suis aujourd'hui
tout d'abord la fois une grande foi foi
en dieu foi en mon prochain foi en moi
même également parce que si je n'avais
pas confiance en moi je n'aurais pas
entrepris un certain nombre de choses
le deuxième élément c'est le don de soi
cet esprit qui vous pousse à vous donner
pour autrui pour votre communauté pour
votre pays
cet esprit qui vous pousse à vouloir
agir et ne pas rester simplement
spectateur
le troisième élément c'est l'engagement
sans réserve la détermination sans
engagement on ne peut rien accomplir de
grands c'est ainsi que ces valeurs là
ont orienté mon choix d'études à
l'université j'ai choisi d'étudier les
sciences politiques à l'université parce
que je me destinais à rentrer en côte
d'ivoire mais plus encore à travailler
dans le secteur public
parce que j'estime et très tôt que c'est
là qu'il fallait être si on voulait
changer les choses
être là où se décident les politiques ou
les grandes orientations pour le
développement de nos états sont arrêtés
j'ai donc étudié les sciences politiques
avec une option sur l'administration
politique au grand désespoir de mes
parents mon père aurait souhaité puisque
lui après une longue carrière dans la
fonction publique a embrassé le monde
des affaires il aurait souhaité que je
suis sa voix ou à défaut que je sois au
moins médecin ou pharmacien qui était à
l'époque perçus comme des professions
très noble mais dire qu'on va rentrer en
côte d'ivoire après avoir eu la chance
de faire des études universitaires au
canada pour être fonctionnaire dans
l'administration ivoirienne
ça peut être perçu parfois comme un
manque d'ambition par les personnes
d'une autre génération et donc j'ai dû
faire face à cette adversité et en
assumer les conséquences
mais étant donné que j'étais certain de
mon choix de ma vocation
j'ai tenu bon et tout le temps qu'a duré
mon bachelor en sciences politiques
j'ai été un pub
d'un petit sobriquet à la maison mon
père ne m'appelez plus par mon prénom
mais il m'appelait sciences po donc à
table sciences po qu'est ce que tu veux
manger sciences po est ce que tu veux
sortir parce qu'il voulait me convaincre
que les sciences politiques me
conduirait au chômage je n'étais pas
certain qu'ils auraient un débouché mais
j'étais convaincu que dieu avait son
plan et que je devais travailler dans
l'administration publique au service de
mon pays et de ma communauté
après donc ses études en sciences
politiques j'ai soumissionner pour deux
masters j'ai été admis à l'école
nationale d'administration au canada et
à l'université laval toujours au canada
pour un master en aménagement du
territoire et développement local
j'ai renoncé à faire l'école nationale
d'administration parce que c'était la
voie royale pour devenir fonctionnaire
au canada ce qui n'était pas ma vocation
je souhaitais vraiment travailler pour
mon pays la côte d'ivoire dont j'ai
choisi l'aménagement du territoire à la
fin de mes études je suis rentré tels
que je m'y étais préparée contre l'avis
de mes parents j'ai assumé ce choix qui
n'a pas été aisée
j'ai connu trois années de chômage vous
avez choisi de rentrer pour travailler
auprès d'un grand monsieur d'un homme
qui fait la fierté de la côte d'ivoire
et de l'afrique s'agit de tidiane thiam
qui était à l'époque directeur général
du net qui était ministre du plan et du
développement et qui était le porteur
d'une grande vision d'un grand projet
que le gouvernement d'alors avait
c'était les dix chantiers de l'éléphant
d'afrique et je voulais absolument être
partie prenante de cet ambitieux projet
et contribuer à cela
donc je rentre en côte d'ivoire je
postule au net
malheureusement pour moi le contexte
économique était assez difficile donc
trois années de chômage mais je ne suis
pas découragé j'ai fait des stages non
rémunérés
trois années durant j'ai travaillé au
met jusqu'à ce qu'enfin au terme d'un
processus de sélection objectif à la
suite d'un entretien je sois retenu pour
commencer une carrière au cabinet du
ministre
tidiane thiam après trois années donc
des preuves
je commence à être carrière là au
cabinet du ministre thiam survient
malheureusement le coup d'état de 99 et
fort heureusement le successeur me garde
dans son équipe et nous voilà à la
primature tout jeune donc à la primature
une belle expérience professionnelle
après cette expérience je me retrouve
appelé honnête auprès du directeur
général d'ubs mais tous ensemble nous
avons conduit un certain nombre de
chantiers la réforme du bnedt la
restructuration de cette entreprise
publique et après cette expérience
quatre années j'ai souhaité voir un
petit peu ce qui se passait dans le
secteur public donc je postule au
ministère de la construction puisque
j'allais mentionné je suis titulaire
d'un master en aménagement du territoire
je suis urbaniste membre de l'ordre des
urbanistes de côte d'ivoire je postule
donc pour le ministère de la
construction
le ministre reçoit mon cv et m'appellent
en entretien il me demande pourquoi un
jeune homme comme vous qui travaille
dans un bureau d'étude venir travailler
dans un ministère dans la fonction
publique
je lui dis parce que j'ai travaillé pour
ce bureau d'études qui est le bureau
d'études qui réalise toutes les études
pour le gouvernement pour l'état de
côte-d'ivoire et qui suit la mise en
oeuvre de tous les projets majeurs mais
la conception des projets se fait au
ministère
il est donc tout naturel que je veuille
apporter ma petite contribution dans la
définition des grandes orientations de
notre politique de développement
il me dit je ne suis pas sûr que ce sera
passionnant pour vous vous risquez de
vous ennuyer ici mais si vous y tenez je
passe votre sévère mon directeur de
cabinet le directeur de cabinet me
reçoivent me pose les mêmes questions et
me dit si vous voulez venir venait pas
de problème et on m'offre un poste de
conseiller technique au ministère la
construction six mois après avec une
dynamique que nous avions engagés je
suis nommé conseiller technique
principal à la tête d'une équipe de sept
conseillers techniques tous plus âgés
que moi
deux ans après je suis nommé directeur
de cabinet adjoint à l'âge de 36 ans de
ce grand ministère ministère de la
construction de l'urbanisme et de
l'habitat
je crois d'ailleurs dans l'histoire de
ce ministère que je suis le plus jeune à
avoir assumé cette fonction
c'est après cela que pour des raisons
des tic je choisi de démissionner ce qui
est assez rare mais qui tient aussi à
mes valeurs à ma conviction est à mon
engagement je ne sais pas me donner à
moitié je démissionne je connais une
période de six mois de chômage avant
d'être sollicité par le président actuel
alassane ouattara puisque en tant
qu'expert j'avais contribué à la
définition de son programme de
gouvernement notamment sur le volet
logement social il me fait appel bien
que n'étant pas membre de sa formation
politique à l'époque pour être à son
cabinet je me retrouve donc conseiller
au cabinet du président de la république
par la suite conseiller chargé des
relations avec l'union européenne
alors que je n'avais pas d'expérience en
diplomatie j'étais urbanisme et ils
m'ont dit tu dois être capable d'assumer
cela honteux responsabiliser on est sûr
que tu vas t'en sortir ils n'ont pas eu
totalement tort puisque vous souviendrez
que la côte d'ivoire a été le premier
pays d'afrique noire a abrité un sommet
union européenne union africaine
il ya bientôt deux ans nous avons réunis
ici à abidjan près de 90 chefs d'état
d'europe et d'afrique tous les
présidents sont venus les premiers
ministres et depuis que la coc div en
écho divorce était la première fois qu
un rassemblement de cette envergure se
tenait et s'est modestement mois dont
qui est piloté ce projet équi et
susciter la candidature de la côte
d'ivoire après ce beau défi relevé le
président de la république me
responsabilise davantage et me nomme
directeur de cabinet adjoint
j'avais 45 ans est conseiller spécial
cumulativement je crois également que je
suis le plus jeune à avoir assumé cette
fonction depuis que la présidence de la
république de côte d'ivoire existe mais
je tiens à préciser que ça s'est pas
fait sans difficulté quand j'ai
mentionné que j'étais directeur de
cabinet adjoint au ministère la
construction entre le moment où le
ministre m'annonce qu'il va me
promouvoir directeur de cabinet adjoint
et le moment ici l'acte de nomination
un an et demi s'est écoulé un an et demi
les coupeurs de route
l'adversité les oppositions mais il est
trop jeune
c'est notre enfant on ne peut pas lui
confier de si lourdes responsabilités
patientant un peu éprouvé le davantage
c'était la même chose à la présidence de
la république entre le moment où le
président de 8 manon ce qu'ils me
nomment directeur de cabinet adjoint et
le moment je reçois effectivement monde
et crée une année s'est écoulée la même
adversité ceci pour dire que lorsqu'on a
une conviction qu'on est engagé sur un
chemin
il faut persévérer surtout pas se
décourager et ne pas baisser les bras
parce qu'au bout du chemin il y a la
récompense lorsqu on persévère
j'ai parlé du triptyque tout à leur foi
engagement sans réserve
don de soi pour autrui
c'est ce qui m'a orienté également dans
mon engagement social qui s'est
transformé en engagement politique par
la suite parce que aussitôt que j'ai
entamé ma carrière professionnelle est
encore chômeurs je me suis engagé pour
ma communauté
ici à grand bassam ça a commencé par la
mutuelle de développement de mon village
où j'étais le plus jeune parmi tous les
aînés tous les tontons ça a un avantage
ça vous permet de vous faire incarner la
drees quand vous engagez je me suis
engagé très tôt ce qui m'a valu en 2011
d'être sollicités pour figurer sur le
ticket du député de grand bassam où j'ai
été donc élu député suppléant en 2011
cette expérience m'a conféré de la
visibilité et en 2015
le président du conseil régional m'a
fait appel sur sa liste où j'ai été élu
avec lui vice-président de la région du
sud comoé cette belle région qui nous
accueille est parmi les cinq vice
présidents j'étais une fois encore le
plus jeune sur cette liste c'est ce qui
par la suite on sait ce qui par la suite
a justifié naturellement qu'on me
propose d'être candidat à la mairie de
grand bassam
c était une élection épique pour ceux
qui ont suivi les médias mais une fois
encore j'ai persévéré je me suis pas
découragé parce que j'étais convaincu
que j'étais appelé à cela à servir ma
communauté
en apportant mon savoir être mon savoir
faire mon dynamisme et ma relative
jeunesse parce que je ne suis plus tout
à fait jeune homme en côte d'ivoire mais
on me dit toujours que je suis trop
jeune
j'ai 47 ans quand même mais on considère
toujours dans certains milieux que je
suis trop jeune
mais ma relative jeunesse à cette
institution municipale et ensemble nous
essayons donc de faire évoluer les
choses c'est une belle opportunité pour
imprimer sa marque montrer qu'on peut
agir différemment gérer différemment les
enseignements que je tire de ce petit
cheminement professionnel de cet
engagement politique et associatif
c'est tout d'abord comme je le
mentionnais la nécessité de persévérer
lorsqu'on a une vision pour son pays une
vision pour sa communauté une vision
pour sa ville
ça peut être une vision pour son
entreprise ou pour son association
il faut persévérer et s'y tenir quelles
que soient les épreuves et les
difficultés il faut également de mon
point de vue être animé d'une bonne dose
de fois pour aborder avec beaucoup de
sérénité
les épreuves qui ne manqueront pas de se
présenter à nous parce que bien souvent
on est gagné par le découragement on a
l'impression qu'on ne verra jamais le
bout du tunnel mais la foi nous aide à
nous surpasser et à donner encore un
petit effort au moment où on s'apprête à
baisser les bras l'autre élément
fondamental c'est vraiment le don de soi
l'esprit de sacrifice parce que sans
esprit de sacrifice
on ne peut pas choisir d'embrasser une
carrière dans le public de gagner
beaucoup moins que nos promotionnaires
qui sont directeurs généraux
d'entreprises privées ou deux banques
d'avoir un salaire plafonné et même
lorsqu'on parvient à redresser des
entreprises ne pas avoir de prime il
faut accepter cela et se dire qu'on
travaille pour le bien commun pour la
communauté pour la collectivité et je
pense que c'est une source importante de
satisfaction de se dire que on contribue
modestement au niveau où on se trouve à
changer les choses et à faire de notre
ville à faire de notre pays un endroit
meilleur pour nous mais également pour
nos enfants
pour conclure je voudrais donc nous
invitez vous inviter à être chacun
d'entre vous quel que soit son
occupation
quel que soit son niveau de
responsabilité un acteur de changement
nous avons le choix entre subir et agir
j'ai choisi d'agir je vous invite à agir
pour le changement pour notre pays pour
notre ville pour notre continent
l'afrique
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]